ça a été l'occasion aussi d'affirmer de
manière claire soit moins ambiguïté
l'engagement sincère l'engagement loyal
l'engagement durable de l'union
européenne aux côtés des partenaires
africains et je dirais que cette réunion
a été l'occasion de donner une impulsion
et l'occasion aussi de la
synchronisation pour s'assurer que snow
actions sont parfaitement conjoints sont
parfaitement cohérente et résulte ce
souhait commun d'être déterminé pour
faire face à cet objectif qui nous
rassemble la lutte contre le venin du
terrorisme et je m'associe bien sûr aux
hommages qui ont été rendus à l'égard de
celles et ceux militaires et civils
européens français mais également
africains qui sont tombés victimes de
cette barbarie terroriste
enfin il va de soi que la transformation
de la situation aux séries doit nous
amener aussi à agir et à transformer la
manière dont nous donnons l'impulsion ce
qui a été fait hier de manière très
claire en accord avec celles et ceux qui
participaient à cette réunion impulsion
pour aller des recettes et articulations
du dispositif et la réunion hier était
extrêmement importante et utile pour se
parler de manière très opérationnelle
très concrète et envisager comment dans
les prochaines semaines et des prochains
mois nous allons imbriquées nos actions
afin qu'elles correspondent parfaitement
à ce qui est utile et nécessaire pour
tenter de faire reculer cette menace
terroriste est d'amener de la stabilité
de la sécurité important aussi plusieurs
l'ont dit de s'inscrire en prenant en
considération bien sûr le sel g5 scène
mais également
l'implication dans le cas de
l'initiative d'accra s'il a été mise en
évidence on a eu l'occasion de montrer
cette ténacité cet engagement à
mobiliser aussi les pays dans cette
initiative qui est bien connu enfin je
conclus simplement en indiquant que dans
quelques heures nous allons avoir
l'occasion d'ouvrir un sommet afrique
europe le premier depuis abidjan une
réunion en personne avec un taux de
participation au plus haut niveau
qui illustre je le crois tant que tu es
européen du côté africain une ambition
commune une ambition commune pour un
partenariat renouvelé tourné vers
l'avenir sincère emprunt de principe
refonder le respect mutuel les intérêts
mutuels la conviction qu'ensemble nous
pouvons rencontrer deux objectifs faire
progresser la paix et la sécurité et
faire progresser le développement la
prospérité
l'afrique est l'heure nous sommes
confrontés au défi de notre temps au
défi pour notre génération et c'est
notre responsabilité de veiller à 6 d
espace de prospérité de stabilité de
sécurité et nous mesurons bien à quel
point sur ce que l'afrique se porte bien
c'est bien et c'est bon pour l'europe
pour ce l'europe se porte bien c'est bon
et c'est bien pour le continent africain
je vous remercie merci beaucoup au
président
nous allons maintenant prendre des
questions une première de jérôme grivet
de la lfp
jean monsieur le président quand vous
faites le bilan des neuf années
d'engagement au mali est récusée vous le
terme échec qui est employé par certains
experts et responsables politiques et ne
craignez vous pas que le retrait du mali
n'encourage ou une favorise un retour
des groupes djihadistes notamment dans
le nord du pays ce qui a ému il réel les
efforts des dernières années
merci beaucoup je récuse complètement ce
terme pour plusieurs raisons la première
que se serait-il passé en 2013 si la
france n'avait pas fait le choix
d'intervenir
vous auriez eu à coup sûr un
effondrement de l'état malien c'était ce
qui était en train de se préparer au
mieux une partition avec un califat
territoriales au pire la prise de
contrôle de l'intégralité du mali par
ces groupes terroristes et les
franchises locales d'al qaïda en
particulier en deçà reding qui avait
sanctuariser son contrôle du mali avait
la capacité de descendre sur bamako
c'était ça la situation de 2013 et donc
j'entends tous les commentaires mais il
ne faut jamais oublier d'où on part et
quel est le contrefactuelle que se
serait-il passé si je vous le dis avec
beaucoup d'honnêteté
c'était ce qui est un ski était alors en
train d'arriver et l'intervention de la
france l'a évité ensuite
nos militaires ont obtenu de nombreux
succès et je citerai pour mémoire la
disparition de l'émir de la katiba al
fort can en février 2019 celle de l'émir
d'aqmi
droukdal en juin 2020 ces disparitions
celle de beaucoup de leurs lieutenants
ont privé l'organisation de capacité à
concevoir et à mettre en oeuvre les
projets d'envergure qu'elle avait
planifiée ce qui fait que la situation
des groupes terroristes aujourd'hui
qu'il s'agisse du nord-mali ou de la
zone des trois frontières est très
différente de celle d'il ya huit ans par
ce travail de cerval fui de barkan et de
l'ensemble de nos partenaires la
deuxième chose c'est que par
l'engagement de l'union européenne au
travers de la mission utm et de tous les
collègues qui sont engagés par la
structuration du g5 sahel nous avons
commencé à consolider
très fortement
les armées africaines de la région et
donc leur situation est aujourd'hui très
différente de celle d'il ya neuf ans ce
qui me fait dire que je ne crois pas au
scénario qui était évoqué après je vais
être très clair et ça correspond au
choix que nous avons fait ce qui a été
dit la france est intervenue au mali
premièrement pour lutter contre le
terrorisme
deuxièmement à la demande d'un état
souverain et des états de la région
c'est cette deuxième condition qui
change aujourd'hui et la victoire face
au terrorisme elle n'est pas possible si
elle n'est pas portée par l'état
lui-même
et pourquoi nous décidons aujourd'hui de
partir parce que
la junte qui est en responsabilité au
mali n'ont fait plus sa priorité
et je veux ici distinguer de manière
très nette les états de la région en
fonction des stratégies qui l'ont adopté
malheureusement dans des états qui se
sont peu engagés dans cette lutte ou qui
ont eu un engagement ambiguë ou tardif
pour des raisons différentes dans des
contextes différentes comme le mali ou
le burkina faso la situation est devenue
hors de contrôle al'inverse si vous
prenez le mauritanie où le la mauritanie
où le niger le travail qui a été fait
intervention des forces son soutien
formation des armées engagements des
états construction d'une armée propre
déploiement d'une politique de retour de
l'état de développement de projets
économiques la stabilité se construit et
la situation je prends l'exemple de la
seule mauritanie a profondément changé
entre 2013 et aujourd'hui est donc
jamais l'intervention d'une armée
extérieure ou d'un état extérieur dans
la lutte contre le terrorisme ne peut se
substituer à ceux qui est le devoir de
l'état souverain nous pouvons venir en
aide appuyez éviter le pire c'est ce que
nous avons fait c'est pour ça que pense
que nous avons réussi quant à cette
mission mais le rôle de la france n'est
pas de se substituer aux états de la
région quels qu'ils soient et où que
soit la région et j'ai toujours été
clair sur l'importance à mes yeux de ce
qu'est la souveraineté territoriale et
du cadre dans lequel nous intervenons
on va prendre une question de bakary nos
journalistes qui sont depuis bruxelles
bakary traoré qui est john journaliste
facture' ivoirien bénéficiaires du
projet de désintox de cff et bakary
bonjour monsieur le président
merci beaucoup pour cette opportunité
alors moi je pose une question au
président d'un peu française dans le
contexte actuel où on voit que la france
fait l'objet vraiment d'une certaine
hostilité envers on le voit sur les
réseaux sociaux est ce que pour les
européens c'est le bon timing pour que
la france soit à la tête du conseil
européen et d une question rapidement
toujours si la france est ce que comment
la france compte utiliser la facilité
européenne pour la paix dans sa
stratégie militaire hausse elle aussi
dans toute la zone dans toute la région
merci
deuxième question c'est aussi le
président jean-michel revenir s'il le
souhaite je vais être très clair avec
vous
il ya une présidence rotative elle
arrive maintenant
c'est un fait et nous prenons nos
responsabilités
le deuxième élément la france joue le
rôle de nation cadre mais notre souhait
de travailler avec l'ensemble des
européens et l'ensemble des pays
africains de la région c'est d'ailleurs
le cadre même de la discussion que nous
avons eue hier et notre manière
d'avancer c'est exactement l'esprit de
takouba est ce que nous avons fait ces
derniers mois travaillés en soutien en
appui avec les armées africaines
concernées et en lien étroit avec tous
les européens qui sont prêts à
travailler avec nous et c'est aussi pour
cela que nous mobilisons des instruments
des financements européens en fonction
des missions mais sur une base simple
c'est l'expression des besoins des états
africains concernés
enfin comme vous je constate ce qu'il ya
sur les réseaux sociaux parfois dans la
rue mais vous êtes journaliste et donc
votre rôle n'est pas simplement de
suivre je crois ce qui se dit mais
d'essayer de comprendre qui parle et
d'où je constate que beaucoup de gens
qui expriment sur les réseaux sociaux
les messages anti français sont des gens
qui sont financés ce sont des activistes
qui sont financés par la russie et par
d'autres puissances qui ont installé en
effet ce discours ce langage on en a
parlé d'ailleurs très franchement hier
et ce discours d'ailleurs vient parfois
frapper des dirigeants plusieurs ici on
tue elle vivre en afrique et donc nous
avons besoin aussi de nous armer car
l'information les réseaux sociaux sont
devenus des lieux de mobilisation pour
parfois pousser les gens à la grande
violence les désinformer et en faire des
des instruments de guerre ou
d'opposition politique et je pense que
ce qui est très important c'est de bâtir
un cadre d'information neutre libre
partout dans nos démocraties mais de
savoir quand on évoque les phénomènes
que vous évoquez d'où ils viennent qui
parle et au nom de qui je vous le dis
très clairement je crois que les
africaines et les africains savent comme
d'ailleurs avec tous les pays les
qualités et les défauts et des gens
qu'on aime qu'on préfère d'autres pas
mais enfin à chaque fois que je suis
allé au manioc dans la région j'ai vu
des femmes et des hommes qui mesurait
l'engagement de nos soldats ce que ça
représentait pour les familles de ces
derniers les sacrifices faits j'ai vu
aussi pas fois des activistes bien payés
dire le pire des contrevérités massive
et donc je pense que notre rôle est de
le dénoncer comme dirigeant et pour vous
de rétablir la vérité comme journaliste
d'un mot je peux affirmer que l'union
européenne notamment sont parfaitement
engagé parfaitement uni parfaitement
rassemblé effectivement nous travaillons
aussi pour améliorer nos capacités de mu
rencontrer les besoins en termes de
l'opération sauter la sécurité de la
stabilité c'est le sens de cette
facilité paix est comme gelée inquiet
tout à l'heure nous avons eu l'occasion
il y reçoit d'évoquer avec les
partenaires africains manière plus
opérationnelles et précises quels sont
les besoins précis que nous allons être
à même de rencontrer union européenne
plus les etam en est d'ailleurs hier la
participation significative de nombreux
leaders européens montrent bien cet
engagement de nombreux états européens
qui partage totalement cette conviction
qui ne suffit pas d'être sur une même
ligne en termes de position politiques
mettent aussi mais aussi d'être
mobilisés avec un leadership français
qui est extrêmement important dans le
cas ça a été dit la présidence rotative
l'union européenne aussi un engagement
pour cette relation entre l'europe et
l'afrique
question de patrick swayze de bfm tv
c'est là tout
le bilan quelques questions sur les
perspectives à très court terme en
lisant votre déclaration commune qui a
été publié juste avant la conférence de
presse vous donner une échéance juin
prochain pour obtenir des perspectives
d'actions communes on a bien senti qu'il
y avait une nécessité d'un partenariat
équilibré respectueux j'entends les mots
du président macro mais aujourd'hui
takouba s'arrête je n'ai pas entendu
président macron dire barkan s'arrête
mais on me corrigera comment vont se
passer les prochaines semaines avec 2400
militaires français qui vont être
concentrés sur la logistique quelque
part est ce que pendant ce temps au mali
alors que la menace se poursuit alors
que 800 à 900 mercenaires issus d'un
pays avec lequel on est plus qu en
compétition on est presque en
confrontation aujourd'hui comment
vous ayez ces prochaines semaines
jusqu'à jusqu'à juin
il s'agit de
redéploiement de la garde collation
au surf de d'armes françaises pour être
très concret sur votre question comme je
les dis nous allons nous avons commencé
à fermer des bases au nord nous allons
donc progressivement fermés dans un
exercice qui va prendre quatre à six
mois les bases qui sont présentes au
mali pendant ce temps nous allons
déployer des forces importantes faux
logistique et de sécurisation de notre
retrait de même que nous allons
continuer d'assurer les missions de
sécurisation de la minus mans durant les
mois à venir nous aurons aussi tout le
travail de dévolution et de réflexion
qui est lui totalement ouvert évolutions
à la fois des exercices eu une thèmes et
de la minus mal
et il s'agit pas ici de préjugés de
quelques évolutions que ce soit ni de
prendre quelques engagements
dans ce contexte nous allons faire ce
travail donc de ré articulations du
dispositif en bonne intelligence avec
les armées maliennes que nous
connaissons bien que nous avons beaucoup
former équiper et financer
vous avez totalement raison de dire que
dans ce contexte il y aura moins
d'opérations de lutte contre le
terrorisme de fait compte tenu des choix
de la junte malienne il y en a moins vu
dans les zones où elle est exposée
puisqu'elle a décidé de ne pas beaucoup
moins travaillé sur ce sujet et il ne
nous appartient pas de nous présente de
nous ici de qualifier la nature de sa
coopération non pas avec un autre état
et je tiens à faire ce distinguo
le mali est totalement libre de d'avoir
des relations de structurer des
relations militaires avec la russie il
en a d'ailleurs eu historiquement depuis
son indépendance
là nous ne parlons pas et le président
poutine la semaine dernière l'a lui-même
officiellement confirmé s'agit pas de
relation entre un état souverain avec un
autre état souverain il s'agit de l'
embauche par la junte malienne sur la
base de financement
qu'il appartiendra clarifier pour le
peuple malien lui même de mercenaires
qui viennent essentiellement sécuriser
leurs intérêts économiques et la junte
elle-même
c'est ça la réalité de ce que nous
voyons
et donc dans ce contexte là ça c'est la
responsabilité de l'état malien je n'ai
pas à les qualifier je n'ai pas à me
substituer c'est pas la responsabilité
de l'armée française nous nous allons en
lien avec les autorités nigériennes et
de toute la région d'abord organisé
cette sortie du territoire malien nous
préservons nos forces qui sont au
burkina faso nos forces spéciales et
nous allons répartie culé autour des
forces qui sont déjà présentes au niger
en lien étroit avec les forces armées
nigériennes le dispositif
qui sera
africano européen je l'avais annoncé
après pau n'djamena
barkan avait vocation à évoluer en
takouba c'est à dire que d'ores et déjà
nous étions en train progressivement on
avait décidé de fermer les bases du nord
et nous étions en train d' européaniser
notre présence avec un dispositif qui
n'était plus un dispositif de grande
base fixe mais qui allait en soutien des
armées de la région et en maintenant des
forces spéciales pour lutter contre les
cibles je dirais les plus importantes du
terrorisme dans la région se disent la
nature de ce dispositif et son esprit
demeure mais il dépend de ce que nous
allons discuter avec nos partenaires
africains dans les prochaines semaines
et les prochains mois et donc c'est
l'expression des besoins des armées du
g5 sahel et de l'initiative d'accra en
lien très étroit avec la cedeao qui va
re calibrer le soutien des européens la
france étant en quelque sorte la nation
cadre au sens militaire de cette
intervention soutien en termes
d'équipement de formation de coopération
et soutient également par des forces
spéciales dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme c'est comme ça que nous
allons réarranger les choses donc s'il
ya un esprit il ya une continuité
complète entre l'évolution de barkan
verte à kouba c'est exactement l'esprit
takouba que nous gardons il ya un
changement de logiciel que nous avons
amorcé il ya à peu près deux ans qui est
de dire on est beaucoup moins sur des
bases installées beaucoup plus en
coopération étroite et en soutien des
armées africaines
l'inflexion qui est porté par nos
décisions de ces derniers jours c'est
que le coeur si je puis dire de cette
action ne sera plus au mali mais sera au
niger toujours dans la zone des trois
frontières et je dirais de manière
peut-être plus équilibrée répartie entre
tous les pays de la région qu'ils
souhaiteront
alors nous repartons à bruxelles dans ce
cas un truchement de l'écran et nous
prenons de questions de wels manie
nouveau journalisme multimédia marocain
vous pouvez y aller
bonjour monsieur le président je suis
journaliste la newsroom arabophone de
ces défis donc ma question sera quel
impact aura la stabilité régionale de la
région de sahel sur les investissements
européens en afrique et est ce que la
coopération européenne avec les pays du
maghreb jouera un rôle dans le
rétablissement de la paix dans le sahel
sur ce sujet je vais dire juste un mot
mais je serai peut-être le président du
conseil européen
l'évoqué plus en détail moi je vais vous
dire deux choses d'abord
nous ne pouvons vaincre le terrorisme de
manière durable que si précisément nous
avons une action qui est beaucoup plus
large que le simple le simple
sécuritaire c'est le coeur de ce que
nous avions décidé à pau et n'djamena
avec après un sursaut militaire ce qu'on
avait appelé le sursaut civile et donc
ont réussi à gagner durablement contre
le terrorisme en faisant revenir l'état
et ses services dans les zones qu'on
libère et en faisant revenir l'éducation
et en faisant revenir les projets
économiques qui permet à la jeunesse de
trouver justement des débouchés
sans quoi très rapidement quand vous
libérer une zone des groupes terroristes
et bien si la population est laissé dans
le non droit c'est la population n'est
pas n'a pas de service public si les
enfants ne sont plus éduqués s'il n'y a
pas de solution économique et de
d'avenir les terroristes deviennent en
quelque sorte des promesses d'avenir
d'un message de mort mais il séduit pour
ces raisons et donc nous avons besoin de
multiplier les coopérations pour
justement gagner cette bataille et plus
largement pour aider l'afrique à réussir
car c' est un continent dont la jeunesse
est un trésor c'est pour ça que dans la
région du sahel dès 2017 nous avons bâti
cette alliance pour le sahel dont je
rappelle les chiffres les chiffres tout
à l'heure
et qui avait vocation qui a toujours
vocation et qui doit continuer de se
renforcer à bâtir des projets sur le
terrain de d'investissement solidaire
permettant de construire des emplois la
grande muraille verte est aussi un
formidable levier dans toute cette
région pour déployer des projets agro
forestiers agricoles agro écologiques
pour créer aussi la des emplois des
opportunités donc oui nous allons
renforcer la france d'ailleurs à
augmenter son investissement dans le
sahel et en afrique ces deux dernières
années très fortement et nous allons
continuer dans l'avenir nous allons
renforcer notre investissement et le
sommet que nous allons tenir l'union
africaine l'union européenne a pour
vocation justement de donner un cadre à
cette nouvelle alliance entre l'afrique
et l'europe avec beaucoup de projets en
matière de santé d'éducation mais aussi
d'investissement et de développement
économiques dans ce contexte les états
du maghreb ont un rôle absolument
essentiel
ils ont un rôle pour assurer la
stabilité et aider à la stabilité du
sahel ils ont un rôle aussi parce que
toute déstabilisation du golfe de guinée
ou du sel à une conséquence directe
négatif sur les états du maghreb qui
sont des états sinon de transit et donc
pense que ce partenariat est aussi un
partenariat infra africains de réussite
dead à la stabilisation et de
développement de projet
d'un mot je pense que africains et
européens quand nous avons travaillé
depuis des mois pour préparer cette
réunion de bruxelles c'est parce que
nous partageons un constat c'est le
constat de l'interaction entre
développement investissement prospérité
et stabilité sécurité et le principe
essentiel de ce sommet que l'on va
débattre bout pour les prochaines heures
et tournées sur la question comment
met-on en oeuvre des projets
opérationnels concrets qui vise à la
fois à canaliser les moyens publics pour
que chaque euro public soit
convenablement investi avec un effet
positif pour la stabilité mais aussi
pour le développement et comment
réussit-on aussi ça c'est très important
a mobilisé ce moment privé avec quelques
priorités essentielles que nous devons
identifier ensemble et il ya évidemment
la volonté de prendre en considération
aussi ce qui relève de la décision des
états africains c'est à dire
l'identification des stratégies
africaines pour attirer davantage
d'investissements pour améliorer les
infrastructures pour faire en sorte que
l'on puisse mobiliser tous les atouts de
ce continent dans le cadre d'un
partenariat qui garantit de travailler à
la fois sur les éléments de
développement d'investissement de
renforcement du secteur privé de rôle
pour les petites et moyennes entreprises
également mais également de faire en
sorte que la le cadre stable et de
sécurité soit un élément attractif pour
réussir cette transformation que nous
souhaitons ensemble est en train
sur cette relation entre investissement
et sécurité je dois dire que le problème
la sécurité la lutte contre le
terrorisme en afrique dépasse le cadre
du cr c'est toute la fève aujourd'hui
qui et qui est atteinte nous devons
rappeler qu'en que la réponse doit être
une réponse globale parce qu'il
appartient d'abord au conseil de
sécurité des nations unies au premier
chef de lutter contre l'insécurité
de promouvoir la paix partout dans le
monde lorsqu'il s'agit de l'afrique je
dois dire que nous essayons aujourd'hui
entre européens africains de bâtir une
stratégie commune mais au delà de
l'europe il faut que tout le monde s'y
met parce que lorsqu'il s'est agit de
lutter contre le terrorisme ailleurs
dans le monde il a fallu de quoi les
champs global il n'y a pas de raison que
quand il s'agit de l'afrique qu'on en
fasse une affaire des africains et de
quelques pays européens ou de l'europe
qui accompagne il faut en mouvement plus
vaste il faut stabiliser l'afrique il
faut promouvoir le développement sur le
continent c'est justement l'une des
raison principale de ce sommet de
bruxelles cet après midi je pense que
les africains eux mêmes se sont engagés
très sérieusement le ghana l'a dit et
nous apprécions naturellement le soutien
de l'europe et la france en particulier
dans ce combat mais c'est un combat qui
va au delà de l'homme et il faut que les
nations unies assument leur
responsabilité est le conseil de
sécurité qui est celui de financer les
opérations de paix qu'il s'agit de
maintien de la paix ou de restauration
de la paix ou de lutte contre le
terrorisme c'est ça que nous attendons
de la communauté internationale au mali
depuis l'été 2020
a décidé de ne plus faire le travail de
sécurité pour son propre pays et comme
je le disais nous ne pouvons pas être
les partenaires d'un état qui ne fait
plus sa part de travail parce que
l'armée française et les armées
européennes seraient dans ces cas-là à
confronter
un travail incessant sécuritaire qui
n'est pas suivie d'un élément de
sécurisation de redéploiement des
services est de retour de l'état la
deuxième chose c'est que cette
transition a été condamné par la région
la cedeao et l'uemoa et que nous avons
ensuite nous même répliqué en tant
qu'européens ces sanctions
quelle cohérence aurions nous
à continuer d'aider un pouvoir politique
qui décide de ne pas respecter les
règles de la transition qu'il s'était
donnée à lui même et qui ne respectent
pas la médiation qu'il a avec le reste
de la région
et enfin la transition malienne a
explicité manière très claire le fait
qu'elle ne voulait plus travailler avec
les européens en renvoyant les forces
spéciales danoise en renvoyant notre
ambassadeur et je le dis encore une fois
de manière très claire nous avons deux
piliers dans notre intervention lutte
contre le terrorisme soutien des états
souverains quand vous avez un état qui
décident de ceux de faire alliance avec
des mercenaires privés qui n'est plus
clair dans sa lutte contre le terrorisme
et qui décide de ne plus travailler avec
vous ça n'est plus dans ces cas là à
nous de continuer à avancer pour moi
cette d'une clarté complète
la clé c'est que derrière par ce
dialogue avec nos partenaires africains
et européens
nous avons réarticuler le dispositif
pour ne pas abandonner le sahel le golfe
de guinée et plus largement le continent
africain par les deux présidents ont
raison ici de rappeler que ce n'est pas
que l'épicentre sahélien qui concentrent
les problèmes de terrorisme voilà la
conférence de presse est maintenant
terminée on aura beau stade et résidents
merci beaucoup